- [Voiceover] James counted
the number of alligators
in various local bodies of water
and graphed the results.
How many fewer alligators
are in Bite Swamp
than Chomp Lake and
Reptile Creek combined?
So, down here, we have this bar graph
that James somehow survived to create
after going to all these bodies of water
and counting the alligators.
We'll hope he was behind
a fence or something.
So then, we're asked how
many fewer alligators are
in Bite Swamp than in Chomp
Lake and Reptile Creek combined?
So, we need to know first
how many are in Chomp Lake
and Reptile Creek combined
before we can figure out how
many fewer are in Bite Swamp.
So, let's look down here.
Here's Chomp Lake sounding super scary,
and it's bar lines up to six,
so there's six alligators in Chomp Lake.
Plus, in Reptile Creek, if we
go over here to Reptile Creek
this bar lines up to nine,
so there's nine alligators
hanging out in Reptile Creek.
Six plus nine, let's
see nine plus one is 10,
so we can make our six
into a a five and a one,
nine plus one is 10 plus
five more equals 15.
So, there's total of 15 alligators
in Chomp Lake and Reptile Creek combined.
Now, we can answer how many
fewer than 15 are in Bite Swamp.
So, Bite Swamp down here,
sounding the most dangerous of them all,
has a bar that lines up to 12.
So, 12, there's 12
alligators in Bite Swamp,
so how many fewer is 12 than the amount
in Chomp Lake and Reptile
Creek combined, 15,
so how much fewer is 12 than 15?
Well, if we have 15 and we take 12 away,
that leaves us with three.
Three fewer alligators in Bite Swamp
than there are in Chomp Lake
and Reptile Creek combined.